Artikel ja schon Puls wenn ich das sehe
das jetzt irgendwelche Steinzeitmenschen
uns dem Westen die Bedingungen diktieren
es ist ja irgendwie den verkehrte Welt
also der taliban-mann sagt wenn ihr
nicht hier verschwunden seid heute in
einer Woche übrigens die Uhr tickt dann
gibt es eine Reaktion wenn man das
einmal genau analysiert was soll denn so
eine Reaktion sein der wird dann
wahrscheinlich kein Brief schreiben
sondern
Selbstmordattentäter schicken das ist
eine ganz klare Kriegs ich würde sogar
sagen Drohung nicht nur Erklärung mit
einem ganz klaren Ultimatum von einem
Verbrecher von einem Terroristen ein
Terrorist diktiert der westlichen Welt
die Bedingungen das ist der Stand am
heutigen Tag das ist nicht nur
bedenklich das ist bedrohlich und ich
bin sehr gespannt was die Staatschefs
als Antwort formulieren und ich habe so
Sorge und Angst dass es wieder ein dahin
betteln wird bitte bitte Taliban man gib
uns mehr Zeit um unsere Leute
rauszuholen da wird er einmal kurz
lachen und sagen dann zahlt dafür und
wir hängen die westliche Welt mit
unseren Werten für die Menschen Soldaten
in Afghanistan gestorben sind hängen wir
jetzt sozusagen an der Gunst eines
Mannes aus einem anderen Zeitalter der
für ein Verbrecherregime steht der für
ein Terroristen eine
Terroristenorganisation steht der für
ein System steht dass Frauen unterdrückt
Menschen steinigt tötet wenn sie sich
nicht an die Regeln halten das ist der
Tiefpunkt der letzten 20 Jahre alt
[Musik]